now about Oscar Knight my deepest hope
is that these two intelligent capable
men have an opportunity to heal talk
this out and reconcile Jada Pinkett
Smith addresses that Infamous Oscar slap
between her husband Will Smith and Chris
Rock and gets candid about living with
scarring Alopecia on the latest red
table talk the more that we can bring
these difficult subjects to light and
talk about it the more we can purify
these subjects let's start by rewinding
to Oscar's night Chris makes a joke
about Jada's shaved head and the actress
looks visibly upset of course Jada has
publicly discussed her struggles with
alopecia a hair loss disease so her
husband will took the matters into his
own hands literally
oh wow at the time A source told E.T
Jada was glad that will stood up for her
and added that she was hurt by Chris's
remark the comedian declined to press
charges and the King Richard actor has
since been banned from future Academy
chance for 10 years Chris has yet to
address the incident directly though he
did poke fun at it at a Dave Chappelle
Show Now Jada is using that Viral moment
to turn a new chapter and she's asking
for a Reconciliation state of the world
today we need them both and we all
actually need one another more than ever
until then will and I are continuing to
do what we have done for the last 28
years and that's keep figuring out this
thing called life together
data also shares how headlines about
Chris's jokes sent the alopecia
Community into an uproar which made her
want to shine a spotlight on the
autoimmune disorder I think that people
don't understand what alopecia is and
they don't understand the effects of it
Jada says one heartbreaking story of a
young woman struggling with the disease
inspired her to educate the audience
about alopecia's effects on March 14
2022 the Rio took her own life she was
only 12 years old
Rio's mom Nikki is here
thank you for being here with us despite
her pain Rio's mom found a silver lining
she said the Oscars controversy created
a shift in the conversation about her
daughter's disorder people are going to
be Googling what is alopecia right right
what is this that we've never heard of
it's not a joke I mean the alopecian
community was already in an uproar we
had heard from so many people I didn't
realize how huge and amazing that
Community is yeah
it's one of those
could have shut up what else yeah if I
really wish it would have found them for
her sooner right instead of them coming
and speaking at her funeral Jada who
first spoke out about losing her hair
back in 2018 choked up over Rio's story
when I heard her story
it affected me so profoundly I feel like
I'm a part of such a beautiful tribe the
alopecia Community is such a beautiful
amazing dress just thank you once again
for your courage and your strength your
willingness to share her light to share
her story to share the story of your
family because it just helps to educate
us all